you can do a thousand things that are
consistent with what you say you're
about and do one thing that's
inconsistent and it wipes out the
thousand the trust is built by an almost
unblemished record of consistency with
what you say you're about founded on the
idea that it's not about you I believe
that that's where the trust really
begins when we look in the social
sectors the great social secular leaders
like Francis have so buying who got all
of these people in the Girl Scouts to go
behind what she was trying to do they
all knew it wasn't about Francis it was
about the Girl Scouts and it was about
the girls and their development and that
is why she had that trust yep
no do I think that all companies peek at
some point in time first I don't know
because there are companies that have
been going for a very long time with a
an incredible record i remember back
when jerry porous and i were doing the
research for built to last and we were
studying walmart and at the time Walmart
was a 25 billion dollar company and that
just seemed gigantic to us and they were
heading to 38 billion and then we we
heard about sam walton's be hagas big
hairy audacious goal that it was going
to be a hundred and twenty five billion
dollar company by the year 2000 and we
thought that's crazy that's huge that's
unmanageable you can't make it that big
they blew right past that they went to
150 billion 200 billion 250 billion 300
billion and sure it still it's hard to
manage at that size but if you would
have asked us in 1994 when we were
writing built to last is it possible to
manage a 300 billion dollar company we
would have said we don't we can't
envision that we haven't seen it well
we've seen it now so I don't know what
the ultimate end is but you can go a
very long time and a very long way think
about a company like procter and gamble
with this a smooth transition to a
next-generation CEO Procter & Gamble was
founded in 1837 okay this is long before
the American Civil War this is long
before reconstruction this is long
before the dissemination of electricity
the invention of telephones this is
before World War one this is before the
depression this is before World War two
I in the United States depression of the
1930s they were 100 years old a hundred
years old and they went right through
that depression they haven't stopped yet
they are still one of the leaders in
their game they're one of the great
consumer products companies in the world
it's been over 150 years Johnson &
Johnson mounted 1886 still on the top of
its game over a hundred years later so
is there an inevitable point two
companies have to hit a wall is there a
point where they camp some staying them
great enterprises well most hit a wall
and we found in how the mighty fall the
whole point was to examine how great
enterprises can self-destruct and over
time most do but so far not all there
are exceptions and to me it is always
the exceptions that are the most
interesting and if there are exceptions
why don't you be one of them